and and we now know
what we expected based upon the way
they're doing the draft roger goodell
will be at home in his basement
according to peter king announcing the
picks one at a time the first night of
the draft i mean where else would he be
they're respecting the stay-at-home
orders he's staying at home the only
question is where in his home will he be
staying when he announces the picks
well and i also wonder you know if he's
had any issues in his household with the
whole you know i.t guy maybe having to
come into his house and set up some
video equipment to do the show and you
know whatever it may be a better
connection to the satellite so nothing
happens that way you know i would love
to hear what roger goodell's uh
household feeling is about that or if he
did anything like that he's just going
to be like us or like me i should say in
front of a computer or an ipad what do
you think you're going to be real
professional or he's going to do
something like i'm doing right now
like have a full-blown real tv camera in
the house i mean i don't know how hard
it is to get the equipment shipped to
you and set it up so you can have that
camera that looks great live in your
house i mean i've had this thing for six
years now ever since we moved into this
place and
now people had to come and set it up i
probably couldn't have done it on my own
it didn't have to even cross that bridge
but my guess is they can have something
that they could send to roger goodell
they could drop it on his porch he could
put it on a tripod press the right
button at the right time and they'll be
able to control everything from bristol
connecticut through espn which is
running the draft and it should look
great it should look far better than it
was shot on a phone and so we'll see or
maybe they want that raw gritty look
maybe they want to simulate what
everything else looks like because they
don't want people to think that that you
know he's got a tv crew in there and if
it looks like a raw real shot like
everyone else has no one's gonna say oh
he's got a full crew of people there
making sure that he looks as good as he
possibly can no no i mean yeah you're
right it's not it's not necessary he
certainly can get it done uh just the
old-fashioned way or the way i'm doing
it right now nonetheless i don't know
how you feel about it i mean i just feel
like i had so many fathers in the
neighborhood
friends of mine continuing you know hey
how are you happy easter stay safe and
healthy so glad the nfl draft is going
to go on i'm bored out of my mind i need
this i'm enjoying your conversations on
the you know on the show every morning
so you know i think there's just a lot
of people in our country that are very
happy and satisfied that the nfl is
going to give us a little entertainment
uh here in a few days and i i think it
is good and just again it keeps us all
you know kind of uh off the news a
little bit and and something a little
more exciting in our lives
i mean these are unprecedented times and
we know that thousands of people are
dealing with the physical realities of
the coronavirus and covet 19 and people
are dying from it but at the same time
there are millions who are trying to get
through their days
at home and they need something to look
forward to i've said many times chris
we're climbing a mountain we have no
idea where the top of it is we are just
taking it one inch at a time in some
cases one millimeter at a time up the
face of the mountain and we need to have
things to look forward to and the draft
is something for everyone to look
forward to who's a football fan and then
the three days of the draft we can
immerse in that and then on the other
side of the draft we got to find
something else to look forward to but
that's how you progress through this for
the millions who aren't physically ill
but who are in a much different reality
than we're accustomed to so i've got no
problem with the nfl going forward with
the draft because i think it does help
the millions who are healthy
physically but maybe having a harder
time mentally dealing with the fact that
it's been over a month now that we've
all basically been locked into our homes
but for those occasions when we leave
for essential reasons chris i haven't
gone anywhere 23 days now i haven't left
the house and uh i want to i part of me
wants to see
how far i can run this streak
although part of me wants to jump in the
car right now and drive down the hill i
mean i'm really torn here because i'm
happy i've been able to stay home but i
kind of want to see what's going on in
the world but everyone resist the
temptation to leave your house unless
you absolutely have yeah that's right
and chris another important thing while
roger goodell is in his house during the
draft peter king explains that there
will be a virtual montage of 15 fans
behind him for each pick who can
interact with him
react to the pick boo the pick if they
choose to boo the commissioner if they
choose to although i have a feeling they
won't i don't think 15 is a large enough
of a crowd for that anonymity that comes
from being in a mob where you can boo
because every year you see it he'll get
booed by thousands but then when he's
interacting individually it's all
handshakes and selfies and everyone's
clamoring for the commissioner
no doubt i you know it's one of those
things where yeah you know people get
more guts with numbers uh but then it
sits starts getting to one-on-one or
two-on-one situations oh hey hey mr
commissioner you're great we love you oh
wait you're a hundred yards away from us
now and i got a thousand people my boo
you stink
yeah i mean that's the way it is that's
life in the nfl that's life as a player
sometimes too
and uh
look 15 is not nearly enough i think to
give someone that cover and also they're
on camera in front of millions and and i
don't know whether or not the nfl
screening process is going to entail the
question of whether or not they'll
commit to not booing but i think they'll
probably get a sense of who they're
dealing with before they plug these
folks in and i think it's highly
unlikely anyone is going to be booing
the commission
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports